[Music]
one day two parallel worlds in myanmar
it was the deadliest day in the country
since the military crew
at least 114 people were killed by
security forces
among them a five-year-old boy meanwhile
the country's military junta staged a
show of might
marking armed forces day among those
attending the parade in the capitan
neptual were fishers
from india russia and china
when the military seized power in
myanmar on february the first
detaining elected officials including
the country's de facto leader aung san
tsuji
chinese state media avoided calling the
coup a coup
instead reporting on a major cabinet
reshuffle
some anti-coup protesters have since
accused beijing of supporting the coup
and the junta demonstrations have been
staged
in front of the chinese embassy in
yangon
so what are china's interests in myanmar
and what does this mean for
international efforts to stop the
bloodshed in the country
china has no access to
the indian ocean and so
you know there are only two access
points for china
to the indian ocean one is pakistan
which is a strategic ally
of china and the other is burma
the burmese port is a very vital
for the chinese the other is the um
burma is is a major strategic
pipeline zone geo's strategic interests
could be one of the reasons why china
along with russia
has so far stopped the u.n security
council from taking strong action
against the military junta and myanmar
but there are other reasons too china
doesn't like protests
that does one thing this is the the
logic that
china doesn't doesn't support the regime
change
even if the regimes are illegitimate
even if the regimes are have taken
over the power in a coup d'etat like in
myanmar
they are it is still not the right of
the people to overthrow a
a government this is the the china's
reading of international
relations for china the alternative to
tatmudo
is a total anarchy in a march resolution
the un security council did condemn the
violence in myanmar
it also called for the immediate release
of aung san tsuji
and other members of the elected
government but it stopped short of
condemning the coup
the eu the us and other countries have
imposed their own sanctions against the
military junta
but human rights organizations such as
amnesty international are calling for a
stronger international response
so the question becomes what can the
international community do
without china china is the bigger
biggest player so um so without china
it's it would be super difficult to do
anything
and that is why china remains the key
player
and there there would have to be
this is a political fiction but there
would have to be a sort of
effort to convince china to change its
position um
to to well to convince china that that
that model is a part of the problem not
the solution
but that would be super difficult given
the current international
circumstances there should be
established
a coalition of states with conscience
and concerns
like like what nato did in his backyard
when
a serbian army and a bosnian militia
were jointly committing genocide
against the bosnian muslims in back in
1990
the language that the military
understand
which is the language of military
intervention
one of the languages protesters in
myanmar have mastered instead of social
networks
we need r2p in myanmar as one of the
hashtags often used by those opposing
the coup
r2p stands for responsibility to protect
the global political commitment by u.n
member states to end the worst forms of
violence
and persecution it is
absolutely impressive that the burmese
people survived
already so long protesting and being
killed on the streets
but the international circumstances are
not favorable for the protesters
unfortunately
there is little hope that the external
world can help the burmese people
if western countries impose further
sanctions on myanmar
that might actually end up benefiting
china
china would be the bigger biggest winner
because if the general win
if the general win then there will be a
repetition of
of of the situation after 1988 with
with myanmar isolated internationally at
least from the west
with sanctions introduced on myanmar and
and this isolation would play well into
the hands of the chinese because the
chinese would then
uh be in much stronger position
vis-a-vis
the the the burmese generals since i
think there is very little
there were the divided world can do to
resolve this
this dramatic situation in myanmar
[Music]
you